ATTENDANCE!DE BUT IT'S 1-0
VANCOUVE, THE WRONG SHOULDER OF
BOESER AND LEAVES AROUND BUT HI
WASN'T EXPECTING THAT.
IT HARD PASS TEES ONE U
JONATHAN TANNER BREAK OUT.
BROWN TO TKACHUK WHO WANTS TO
HEAD TO THE BENCH SO RICHARDSON.
THERE'S AN OTTAWA PENALTY COMIN
OF HIS REACH, BUT NOW MILLER
SENDS THE PUCK TO THE SIDE.
HUNT IS THERE.
IN THE CORNER, J.T.
>> John G.: YES.
>> John S.: AND STILL FIVE GAMES
CANUCK GOAL.
DEMKO FAKED ONE WAY, WENT THE
LONG WRIST SHOT.
>> John S.: SO A GOOD START TO
THE PERIOD FOR THE SENATORS
CORNER FOR EKMAN-LARSSON.
HE'S BODIED BY STÜ
TO CALL GOAL 2-2.
BUT STÜTZLE COULDN'T FIND THE
NET. THE NET.
OFF T TTORS LOVE TO GET BEHIND
DEFENCE AND HERE THEY ARE BEHIND
THE  HASASN-FOUR HOCKEY.
A LITTLE OPEN ICE.
FEEDS IT IN FRONT AND A SHOT BY
MILLER SAILED WIDE OF THE SHORT
SIDE.
WIDE OF THE
GOAL.
BRANNSTROM BACKHANDS THE PUCK
BEHIND THE NET.
AN-LARSSON TAKESE
PUCK BEHIND THE NET, PUTSHEIR G.
HUGHES THE OTHER.
OTTAWA IS 3-5. TRYING TO CHECK
FORMENTON BRINGS THE PUCKKHOSE
FIRST FOR OTTAWA AGAINST
THATCHER DEMKO.
DEMKO STOPPED 10 OF 12 THIS IS
SHOOTOUT OF THE SEASON WHERE
FILIP GUSTAVSSON WHO IS ORES!
>> John G.: OH, MAN.
[ Horn ] JUST MISHANDLED IT
AND IT
ALIVE.
>> John S.: CONOR GARLAND.
ROUND FOUR SHOOTER FOR
FIVE GETS HIS FIRST CAREER
SHOOTOUT ATTEMPT.ohn S.: NOW TH
ADAM GAUDETTE, CHANCE TO WIN